you might think there's nothing better
than settling in for a good old stranger
things binge watch
or turning in on a nostalgic disney
classic we'll be taking your favorite
princesses and princes through a magical
portal into the 80s
reimagining them as the radical stranger
things characters
what if rapunzel had telepathy just like
11
flynn rider is spending this video
switching his prince chic
for a nautical vibe and merida she may
be keeping her fierceness but her
wardrobe is getting a very
high wasted makeover
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
stranger things in disney may have
absolutely nothing in common
but you have to admit they would make
one heck of a crossover
just remember you saw it here first
don't forget to let us know what your
favorite reimagination was in the
comments section below
make sure to hit that subscribe button
and give this video a thumbs up
thanks for watching